Your whole outfit
doesn't make any sense.
You look like a
Disney Channel version of slave Leia.
Meaning
I’m only one eighth hard.
My bracelets are so strong
they can stop bullets.
If anyone shoots you at that
hot zone.
The human wrist.
While I'm here.
Usually do it at the end,
but I'm going to mix it up.
Wow.
Yeah.
And you can't fire me.
I'm the only woman.
It would be a P.R. nightmare.
I actually thought about that.
See,
women are all, like,
treat us equal.
So if I
don't fire you
and I’m firing everyone else,
that actually makes me
a NON feminist.
I do not think
you get to decide if you're a feminist.
Oh, no.
Let me batsplain this to you.
You're a lady.
No need you no mo.
Finish the sentence.
Sweetie,
Let me batsplain,
what sexism is to you.
Real quick.
When a man
pretends to trust a woman.
Oh, wow.
Let me put this in terms
a woman will understand.
Oh, that's offensive.
When a cake is done,
and your husband is hungry,
Take it out,
then bring it to him.
But then, come back in the kitchen
while he eats it.
There’s not even a logic to it.
I am Princess Diana
from Themyscira.
You mean that hot
lesbian island?
With horses.
Right.
Do they ever get in the mix?
I’m so sorry.
That's the line?
That's the one.
You took the time to add
ears to your helmet.
So, my ear is here
and I'm wearing hearing aids
and these are like, little
AM antennas.
Sometimes I pick up
Wait, wait, don't tell me.
Paula Poundstone,
you devil.
How did you think of that so quickly?
In your corduroy blazer.
That was, good.
That's my demographic.
Oh, an NPR joke
i’m on the floor.
What are your deepest,
darkest secrets?
Please no!
I don’t even know what a bat is!
Some kind of raven?
It doesn't sound right.
I don't brush my teeth,
but I do run my toothbrush
under the faucet to fool Alfred.
He's always checking on me.
I'm like, Hello?
My parents are dead.
Let my mouth, bones rot
you British bitch!
Sometimes I look at my butthole
in the mirror just to check in.
Check what?!
Just, you know
anything new going on?
I have a deeper secret identity
sh*t d*ck, Daniels!
Except when I put on a fake beard,
and go to open mics
and do prop comedy
under the name
Gary Gillespie!
What's Gary got in his bag of tricks today?
A slide whistle
that's also a dildo.
They're all
also dildos.